فلاحظات للتاريخ سجلها مونديال قطر ستبقى
لمده طويله في اذهان عشاق كره القدم
مونديال قطر البطوله الاولى من نوعها التي
تقام في الشرق الاوسط في الشهرين نوفمبر
وادي سنبر بعد ان تعود عشاق الكره على
اقامه المونديال صيفا طوال النسخ الماضيه
المونديال العربي هو المونديال الاول الذي
يشهد تالقا عربيا لافتا تمثل بوصول المغرب
للمربع الذهبي وتحقيق المركز الرابع فيما
حقق المنتخبان السعودي والتونسي انتصارين
للتاريخ اماما الارجنتين وفرنسا مونديال
20 22 شهيده لاول مره قياده تحكيميه
نسائيه لمباريات وتحديدا في مباراه
المانيا وكوستاريكا التي قادتها الفرنسيه
ستيفاني فابرد بمساعده البرازيليه لويزه
باك والمكسيكيه كارينز البطوله الحاليه
لاكبر نجوم العالم خلال سنوات الماضيه
وعلى راسها ليونيل ميسي ورونالدو وسواريز
ولوكا مودريتش ان اعظم مونديال قطر على
الاطلاق فهي لحظه تتويج ميسي والارجنتين
بكاس العالم بعد مسيره تاريخيه لميسي